hello and welcome to quad Riga
DWS international talk show I'm Brian
Thomas and this is our u.s. election
special coming to you from the heart of
the German capital Berlin well it was
the shot heard round the world the
election of Donald Trump to America's
highest office and what's called the
most powerful position in the world
Trump has promised a second American
Revolution and now his supporters will
expect him to deliver on that promise in
his acceptance speech he offered
reconciliation with those across the
political divide Hillary Clinton didn't
take the stage as hoped as the news
broke and her bitterly disappointed
Democrats are now wondering what a
Donald Trump presidency will mean for
them Donald Trump has promised to put
America first including when it deals
with his friends and enemies abroad what
can Americans and what can the rest of
the world now expect from a Donald Trump
presidency to talk about that I'm happy
to be joined now in the studio by our
guests Mathew carnage Megan he's the
chief European correspondent for
Politico based here in Berlin he says
we're witnessing the revenge of the
disenfranchised white working-class and
not just in the u.s. Trump is everywhere
we're also at Tom gala he's a seasoned
political journalist who focuses on
American and security affairs he says
the new President will urge Germany to
substantially increase its defense
spending and we also happen to have with
us a Nozawa bride from the Berlin Daily
debt August beagle she's also an op-ed
writer for The New York Times and she
says Donald Trump's victory marks a new
era in European security politics we are
now on our own thanks so much to all of
you for being here on what is definitely
an historic day certainly the biggest
political event of my life Matthew let's
start with you if we could is this the
beginning of a second American
Revolution what we're what were your
reactions as the numbers rolled in well
it was interesting because I think that
we were all shocked even though I knew
this could happen
and you know thought ahead of time well
if he wins I won't really be that
surprised and yet I was surprised I
think everybody was really shocked and
there was this moment of what
this really mean is it a second
revolution I don't really know and I it
reminded me a little bit of you know
what what happened after the terrorist
attacks of 2011 to be honest 2001 that
you know really didn't know where it was
going to lead and that's sort of how I
feel right now is that this is
definitely a watershed moment everything
is gonna be different after that but
what it looks like I don't think anybody
can say with any real certainty yeah
what do you think an emotional
outpouring you know that what kind of a
what can we expect to happen in America
and here in Europe following this and is
it a revolution for you you've been to
America you were just there for three
weeks this summer do you think it's a
second American Revolution no I don't
think so it's um it's not a revolution I
think that now voices are being heard
that haven't been heard before but these
people have been there and they have
been there for decades maybe they got a
little more they have now found an
outlet for what they wanted to express
and they have expressed it but that
doesn't really change the country the
country has been divided all along
Obama's second term at least and as for
Europe I think it's too early to say
what it really means for us because
Donald Trump as many populist has been
very vague in everything he's been
saying during his campaign and now
everybody is sort of quivering and
awaiting what his very bold statements
really and live up to in the reality to
find out not only what the fine points
of policy are but who and how they'll be
enacted right who will be enacting them
Tom what do you think are we looking at
a new revolution what were your what was
your reactions you watched all those
blue states turn red right so I'm not
not surprised that I strongly disagree
with what you both have said before
because if you would have followed the
internet you would have seen that the
opinions on the internet especially from
young people were extremely different
from what was published by the
mainstream media's especially from the
New York Times which really is a great
disappointment because for the first
time in its history it became biased and
to support it they're on the road to
Canosa now aren't they they're they they
have to but let me come back to is it a
revolution no it is a change again
didn't President Obama's
start with change and president-elect
Donald Trump said earlier today in his
speech
ours is a movement and that is what I
really can underline it's a movement
okay and actually look at the results
it's the majority of America who is
behind him so it's not is a strong man
it is not a divided country it is a
united country actually ok this that's
an interesting town encounter theory now
Matthew I'd like to ask you about you
know what tom was just talking about
here you know how the media got it so
much of the media got it so wrong yeah
you're with Politico what happened what
happened over there you guys were
looking at you know Trump going down in
flames to Hillary Clinton how did the
media get it so wrong were they not
looking at those huge Trump rallies well
I think there's a fixation with polls
and I think people were very focused on
the polls and that really is as a
journalist all you really have to orient
yourself by is to look at the polls and
see who's winning the horse race I sort
of disagree that the media was you know
implying that it was inevitable that
Clinton was gonna win if you remember
just a little over a week ago when the
FBI chief came out and said that was
males and and all of this there was all
of a sudden all over the press was like
wow you know this is could be a game
changer and and and Trump could win and
then again over the weekend
the FBI chief came out again and said
well we didn't we didn't find anything
and it wasn't literally clear what that
was going to mean so yeah I've had so
many events over the past six months in
this campaign that the famous Trump
video for example you know all of the
stuff with with with Clinton's staff
with the foundation the Clinton
Foundation it really was very difficult
to tell and I I think you know the the
result is you know ultimately surprising
because the polls were very wrong and
why were the polls wrong well one reason
is is that this segment of the
population the white working-class
whites has proved very difficult for the
pollsters to gauge maybe because they're
modeling is wrong or probably because
they're modeling Israel a lot of times
when the polls will talk to the same
people repeatedly over the course of
excuse me they might be trying to
include too many minorities basically
and it's not really PC to to just focus
on whites we're
PC could this be the end of the PC era
you know and you were in the u.s.
reporting and you said you talked mainly
to minority Americans black Americans
was that a mistake to just talk with
them and not get out there to white
America that was just a focus of my
research there but I think that it still
was good to look at them because we see
a certain disappointment among the
minorities with Hillary Clinton too and
that is part that's one piece in the
puzzle why she has lost because she
hasn't had the black turnout like Obama
has had and she has lost among the
Hispanics to so many among the the
Hispanic voters feel they are not
represented by the Democratic Party and
I think it is important to look at the
minorities okay so it's not just the
white lash as it's being called a
backlash from white America it's where
most of about that cast ballots come
from but it's also it's also that she
wasn't as strong with Democratic
strongholds as she should have been okay
Tom you were saying it you know America
is united again do you think they're
uniting behind nation god family the
three points that that Trump always
emphasizes that certainly plays a role
but also simply the results that Trump
could win at classical Democratic
households this is what plays a role and
this is what actually I think unites
America behind him because he does not
belong to the establishment almost
everyone hates the the DC pundits and
Clinton simply stood for that stood for
a slick enos and lies and whatever and
it is a kind of in this respect a kind
of revolution and uprising the New York
Times was calling it this that this
morning as well an uprising the country
is united behind Trump I mean of course
he is one the majority but still there's
Democratic households this is actually
has one in the backyard of mrs. Clinton
he has he cares for the ordinary people
he cares for the working class which for
a long time the Democrats said this is
ours and it's not theirs
they're showing their disappointment
they feel among the abandoned the
abandoned that had gone in what's called
math you know if you've heard this
expression is called the monster vote
you know if you've been following that
at Politico all these people out there
that that haven't ever voted before or
haven't voted in a long time showing up
apparently we're gonna crunch all these
numbers over the upcoming days you know
in mass numbers to turn out this this
vote the way it turned well I mean all
you have to do is look at at his rallies
and you know a lot of people look at
rallies saying oh well you can you know
always get a bunch of kooks together to
come to somebody's rally but if you
compared Trump's rallies which were
always full and rockets and people
really had a problem with Hillary
Clinton's rallies where you know in some
cases you could really hear the crickets
in the background hey stars like Jon Bon
Jovi or jay-z and so forth they had a
lot of people there but you know despite
these demographic changes in the US
which really dominated the narrative at
the beginning of the campaign that well
Trump as a white guy you know who's
pushing all these racial buttons is not
going to be able to win in today's
America that proved to be wrong and the
reason it proved to be wrong is that
forty percent of the electorate still is
white and is working-class actually more
than 40% and 70% of the overall
electorate is white so despite these
Democratic shifts most of the voters are
still whites and Trump was the one as
you were saying you know who really
spoke to their concerns but the problem
is it's not really clear what he's going
to do about it and and you know there's
been a lot of promises and you really
have to wonder because we don't really
know what his policies are going to be
beside from building a wall and so forth
where he's going to be in four years and
if he's really going to be able to keep
those people behind it his records are
far it tells us that he's really going
to be the person for the working-class
white American well he'd say and we
don't need Tom to do this time well you
would jump in what would eat what would
Donald Trump say actually I think we
know a lot what Donald Trump is going to
do and nobody knows what he will do in
four years we didn't know that President
Obama would would do such a lousy
politics when he started I mean we were
all full of hope and what came out was
that he became an announcement president
without doing something so who if this
president who also announced quite a lot
would would fulfill only half of it he
would be way more successful than his
predecessor let me come to that you say
we don't know what he's going to do he
in every speech he made out some very
specific policies especially for example
when he said today in his speech is that
I'm reaching out to the world what I say
to you we want partnership and not
conflict I mean this was already a
message to the world I am NOT I'm not
the bad guy
I was printed let's go listen to his
speech in just a bit here he also held
out a very big olive branch Hillary
Clinton didn't he a woman who just a few
days ago he was saying you know put
Hillary in Carole you know not only
drain the swamp you know put Hillary in
jail let's give a listen to this clip
from that that speech right now where
Donald Trump calls for reconciliation
and unity Hillary has worked very long
and very hard over a long period of time
and we owe her a major debt of gratitude
for her service to our country I mean
that very soon so now it's time for
America to bind the wounds of division
have to get together to all Republicans
and Democrats and independents across
this nation I say it is time for us to
come together as one United people I
pledge to every citizen of our land that
I will be President for all Americans I
was personally very impressed by that
that acceptance speech I was almost late
for the show because I had to listen to
it in its entirety as well as get the
kids ready I know man I was dealing with
that as well
what do you make of the speech did he
hit all the right tones was it gracious
well I mean I think he hit everything
that you would expect someone in his
position to do he won it doesn't cost
him anything to extend an olive branch
to Hillary Clinton but I'm not sure many
people are gonna buy it I mean to give
it given the things that he said during
the campaign
you know every stopped he called her
corrupt he was always referring to her
as crooked Hillary so now that he's one
to come out and say oh well we really
thank her for public service I mean you
know a few days ago he was saying that
he was going to invest have her
investigated if if he if he won the
election so III think it's really you
know something that her supporters are
not going to say oh well this is just a
normal election all's well that ends
well maybe we'll win next time I think
it's going to and I also disagree I
think the country is very divided
divided in a way that it's polarized you
know he did get you know I don't even
know if he got a majority of the popular
vote but he got certainly a majority of
the electoral vote someone won the
country but I've never in my lifetime
seen this kind of hate in the American I
agree with you on that Matthew one of
the things I've always been proud about
as America's lack of political violence
we saw it in a big way during this
campaign
very disappointing you didn't see it at
all in the brexit the brexit debate went
on nigel Farraj was never roughed up
there was never any difficulties you
know and what do you think when you look
at this acceptance speech you know does
it change your mind at all about that
one from if that's a new Donald Trump
all the better but I find it hard to
believe that and I mean he says that at
a moment as soon as you said where it
doesn't cost him much but where it would
cost him to say something different
because it's at a point where the
markets aren't free-falling and money is
moving from the dollar to the euro and
the Asian markets are upset so it's the
same thing after brexit people came out
and said well calm down let's calm the
markets that's come the political mood
let's calm the world and then we move on
so it's a smart thing for him to do as a
businessman it's a responsible thing to
do as a politician but I'm not sure
that's what we're going to see during
the next four years let's look at the
politics of this Donald Trump did paint
himself into the corner with the crooked
Hillary meme with saying she needs to be
good to go to jail I'll appoint a
special prosecutor how does he now get
himself out of that situation
how does he extend an olive branch
across the aisle to the Democrats who by
the way he really won't need to deal
with because the Republicans have won
the house and the Senate have to say
that
but still to unite the country how does
he get out of this position now a
president always can you know pardon
someone as mrs. Clinton's husband did so
he has always a chance to get out of
this but again let me refer to what you
both said before no matter what Donald
Trump is going to say you distrust him
so don't you think you're both kind of a
bit biased no matter what he says let me
say if he would not have been gracious
to mrs. Clinton you would have said look
at him that's typical him and now he was
gracious and it's wrong again or or you
don't buy it I mean this is a kind of
bias I really do not understand oh it's
not that I personally distrust him I
don't really have a view on it I'm just
saying that Hillary supporters the
Democrats in the country are going to
watch that speech and I think that they
will probably many of them come to the
conclusion you know he's just saying
this because somebody told him that he
has to and and there's no doubt whether
you like him or not that that he had a
campaign it was really a scorched-earth
policy also in terms of the relations
with with the United States allies in
Europe and elsewhere and there are a lot
of questions in Europe within NATO in
Eastern Europe about the United States
is commitment to the NATO alliance going
forward we get to that in this show
we're gonna talk about this I want to
talk about right now how we overcome
these divisions you know looking at this
campaign you know Matthew Earth Politico
it's like each side has its own media if
you're a conservative you read breitbart
you read you know the hard right stuff
you go to Alex Jones you know if you're
more liberal you go to Politico you read
the tiger Spiegel if you all know what's
happening in your city you know how do
we bridge these divisions everyone's in
their own little Facebook and Twitter
kind of kind of their own lane I don't
think you can I don't think you can
bridge them and I don't think it really
isn't matter if you're liberal you read
this or if your conservative you read
that if you're reading some of these
places that are not really fact-based
you can read fact-based media that draws
on what is actually happening and what
is being said and what somebody's record
is you can read those and draw your own
conclusions or you can read some of the
places that you're talking about that
live in a parallel universe and are
running this narrative that is is just
is fictional
just said that's not a parallel universe
that is the universe well that doesn't
change the fact you know I mean if
that's the really want to live in that's
that's you know that's there right but
you know I think it's responsible
journalist you can't say oh well you
know this is what people want so we all
just have to start making this stuff up
okay we can't pretend that he didn't say
the things that that he did what's the
word Spiegel when people talk about this
you know how is your viewership or your
readership doing over there I mean I I
don't I think our readership is a very
classical newspaper readers um but we
see the same thing in Germany they are a
group that is growing smaller and you
can watch it growing smaller because
it's the median here are not as divided
as they are in the United States but we
see similar blocks like Breitbart or
else Joe Alex Jones popping up here in
Europe too and they have increasing
readership too so I think this is also a
lesson we can learn here in Germany as
to how bubbles are forming and I think
that part of the success from for the
AFD that we have seen in elections here
this year is also supported by those
alternative media that are popping up in
the country mm-hmm is that a danger to
democracy you know did this democracy
get at some point gets so fragmented
it's difficult to get a consensus I
think we have to be careful to call it a
danger to democracy because now we have
to be good losers as progressives to and
we have to say well this is what the
people want it and if they draw have
drawn this conclusion if they have come
to the voting decision by living in
those parallel universe we still have to
accept what they perceive as their
reality and we have to address that so I
wouldn't call it a danger to democracy
but we certainly have to find paths to
talk to those people again okay finding
paths to talk to one another Donald
Trump made that difficult with onla
Mackel when he said on Allah Michael has
ruined Germany referring to the
migration crisis how does Donald Trump
now make a bridge across that statement
well I think you know Merkel was very
smart throughout this by not addressing
Trump by not reacting to that and and by
not going after him in the way people
like Steinmeier and some of the other
German polit
since did because she recognized the
importance of the United States as an
ally to Germany so I think you know the
relationship will be remain above this
for the Germans and I think that she'll
look the other way as she had in the
past if you look at you know the way
miracle dealt with Berlusconi the way
she dealt with Sarkozy other people who
were difficult partners I think you know
this will be forgotten I don't think
they're ever gonna be bosom buddies
mariculture it's politics and she
understands that was the the campaign
but the the stats that I saw is the
Germans call it has to rise above that
you think that's what's gonna pan out
Tom this this might be true for Germany
because Juri always thinks it can get
get away but I don't think that this is
the case with Donald Trump because he
used Angela Merkel for his campaign and
this was the first time I remember that
any German politician ever played a
quite significant role in an American
election because he called Hillary
Clinton and American Americans Angela
Merkel okay I have to say this is tied
to a hot-button issue in America that's
the migration debate so I think it was
more related to the issue than the
person Ivana lemarchal that would be my
take on it we have heard today from the
German Foreign Minister we have that
soundbite German Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier says the results
of the u.s. election were not what
Germany had been expecting but added
that Germany accepts the results in any
case time Meyer also said that he hopes
that there will be no major disruptions
in international politics let's give a
listen in the course of the election
campaign Donald Trump has made critical
remarks not only about Europe but also
about Germany I think that we must
adjust to the fact that American foreign
policy will become less predictable in
the near future and we must adjust to
the idea that America will be more
inclined to make decisions on its own
okay America will be more inclined to
make decisions on its own I want to pick
up on once
EPIK policy area and that is Syria right
now there's been a lot of pressure on
Germany by the Obama administration to
back a possible no-fly zone American
no-fly zone over Syria we've heard some
background discussions here in Germany
about that how do you see that going
what's up with you Anna well let's see
what drama Trump makes of it because
that's another policy areas too he
hasn't really said what he wants to do
in Syria and people have tried to push
him on whether he wants to put ground
troops into Syria and he hasn't really
answered that I don't think Germany
would by any means and with any American
president follow America and put ground
troops into Syria but possibly a no-fly
zone with the Bundeswehr aircraft yes
but in his in his policy paper he says
on Syria he says he wants to build or
work with coalition's and and that's
what Obama has been doing all along and
I guess that Germany giving the Priven
the pressure to to have peace in that
region here and very concretely for us
here in Germany well we'll follow along
a certain way what do you think um I
think I would like to refer to John
Louis quote saying America will be less
predictable what can be less predictable
than the Obama administration because
Obama announced and announced and never
did something except of actually causing
also causing the this this migration
from Syria so actually I think we will
have a more predictable politics from
Trump which might not be to the
satisfaction of the Germans or which the
Germans might not like however I think
he will be more predictable okay there's
a very important issue for Germany the
Syria war isn't I yes no it's very
important for Germany it's important for
everybody I would just say to that
briefly Trump himself has said he thinks
America needs to be less predictable on
the world stage so you might disagree
with you on that point but clearly this
is the type of issue where he's going to
have to make a decision and it's going
to have very important strategic impact
in the Middle East and for European
allies and we really don't know which
way he's leaning or where it might go
whether there's a fly zone or whether
their troops or really the bigger
question is what do you do about Syria
it's a complete disaster and nothing is
gonna happen there now for the the
lame-duck period over the Quadra
pressures of our Thom McAn Obama yeah
there's a lot of partition pressure but
there's and then the whole relationship
with Russia and I think that's really
the key question is how does that play
out what really are his views of Russia
of Putin and where is that going to go
there right now which is running out of
time I wanted to talk about NATO let's
bring that in as well NATO Russia what
is Donald Trump going to do about NATO
and Russia big concern of course for
Germany a very close neighbor and I'd
like to hear your thoughts on that
I'd love to know what Donald Trump
really wants to do about NATO but I
think I think that there won't be that
much change there because with Obama's
policy pivot to Asia of giving more
responsibility to the Europeans Europe
sort of had many years to prepare for
that moment where America was going to
leave us alone
so there was 60,000 troops here I mean
in Germany's that has started to react I
mean Angela Merkel has announced this
summer that the defense budget would be
bolstered it won't it still won't be
enough to fulfill the 2% line often that
NATO has given itself but I think we're
going in that direction already and
maybe we have to speed up a little bit
now but it maybe it won't be such a
radical change for Donald Trump is
indicated he wants 3% of GDP spent on
defense that's the number he has out
there is that realistic Matt what do you
think well it's not given the current
political climate in Europe where in
most of Europe is in economic stagnation
and has difficulty paying the bills that
they have now to think that France Spain
countries like that are gonna start
spending 3% of GDP is a little bit
unrealistic and I think this is one of
the big questions is where he goes with
NATO what does he want from NATO what
does he think the United States is role
in in Europe should be and I agree that
he will continue to shift to Asia
because he sees China and he's right on
this as the only existential threat that
exists to the United States now so it
was natural that he would that he would
shift more to China if
Linton had one she probably would have
been or definitely would have been the
last transatlantic president and I think
this is one of the big sort of important
points here is that the United States is
going to continue under Trump to a draw
from Europe Europe is going to be much
more left to its own devices on issues
like Ukraine and probably on issues like
Syria as well okay could we be looking
at then at post transatlantic presidents
say very possibly I I don't see anything
that would stop it I he you know he
wants to have a close relationship with
the UK that's another result of this
election we could have a new sort of
flowering of the special relationship
okay Matthew thanks to you so very much
I'd like to thank all our guests for
being with us here in the special
edition of quadri new quadriga matthew
carnage Nick from Politico ana Sawa bye
from dead tiger Spiegel also New York
Times and of course Tom gila seasoned
political journals thanks so much for
being with us and thank you for being
with us as well as America in the world
moves into a new era the era of a Donald
Trump America I'm Brian Thomas we'll see
you again next time